le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais depuis sa création la
télévision a évolué de manière
fulgurante aussi bien techniquement que
par ses contenus le mode de transmission
aussi a muté hertiien puis satellite
Internet et TNT cela fait maintenant
plusieurs générations que la télévision
fait pleinement partie de notre
quotidien dans la quasittalité des
foyers ces contenus ont énormément
d'impact sur notre société mais la
multitude de chaînes et la diversité des
programmes reflètent-ell vraiment la
diversité de notre culture et de notre
société on en parle maintenant dans lien
social la majorité des foyers réunionnés
regardent la télé pour profiter de leur
programme favori les informations et les
divertissements il y a à peine 20 ans
les réunionnés ne pouvaient profiter que
de trois chaînne dans des créneaux
horaires assez restreints puis il y a eu
l'arrivée des antennes satellites avec
des services proposant des dizaines de
chaînes provoquant même l'embarras du
choix dans ces deux cas nous regardions
nos programmes de la même façon très
souvent aux heures imposées et sur un
poste de
télévision internet est en train de
changer nos habitudes puisque maintenant
en plus des grilles de programme
traditionnel la plupart des chaîne offre
la possibilité de regarder ces émissions
en allant sur
Internet cette technologie permet aux
téléspectateurs de choisir ce qu'il
souhait visionner et au moment où il le
souhait ce service pratique et moderne a
interpellé la présidente du conseil
général elle a rapidement pris
l'initiative de créer une web TV pour
que les réunionnés puissent entre autres
s'informer à tout moment des dispositifs
qui leur sont offerts par le conseil
général dans la continuité de cette Web
TV le département a décidé de proposer
une chaîne avec des contenus choisis
dans l'intérêt des réunionnés l'idée
étant de respecter la ligne de conduite
et le devoir du conseil général à savoir
apporter des services et des solutions à
tous les
réunionnés alors 974 télé a la vocation
d'être au service des réunionnés d'abord
et avant tout c'est la télé du conseil
général mais c'est surtout la télé des
runiones AL je vais vous donner un
exemple très concret vous avez dansos
dans votre entourage une personne qui
est malentendante vous voulez
communiquer avec elle il vous faut
apprendre le langage des signes
apprendre le langage des signes ça
nécessite de se déplacer d'aller dans
une réunion en vis-à-vis avec un
professeur mais là le professeur il sera
dans la télévision et vous pourrez
apprendre le langage des signes gratuit
uitement sans vous déplacer sans avoir à
prendre votre voiture simplement vous
assantre devant votre télévision alors
ça va peut-être concerner 50 100 200
réunionnés mais au moins sans objectifs
financiers puisquil y a pas de publicité
dans 974 télé vous aurez la capacité de
mieux communiquer avec une personne
malentendante tout en découvrant un
moyen et une façon de communiquer qui
est vraiment au service de la plus
grande majorité de rignonnais concept de
base de 974 télé c'est d'être dans
l'esprit du web l'esprit des pages
facebook l'esprit de daily moion ou de
Youtube c'est faire de petites émissions
de petits formats 3 minutes 6 minutes
mais faire en sorte que vous veniez
piocher dans les contenus dans la grille
programme de NOK télé et que vous
découvriez ben l'émission qui est
diffusé au moment où vous allumez votre
télé et vous y soyez accroché et que
pendant 3 4 5 6 minutes vous intéressiez
à une histoire à un service du conseil
général à un portrait de réunion est
formidable et peut-être encore mieux à
un contenu audiovisuel qui aurait été
produit par vous grâce à votre
smartphone grâce à votre appareil photo
qui fait la vidéo grâce à une petite
application sur votre tablette et vous
allez nous envoyer un contenu de la
balade du weekend dernier ou de la jolie
fleur qui a pousser dans le jardin de
belleemaman et vous allez nous raconter
vous aussi votre petite histoire et on
la diffusera sur 974 TL 974 télé c'est
la télé des rignonnis et c'est une télé
participative à l'image du savoir vivre
ensemble cette chaîne de télévision
permet aux réunionnés de continuer de
partager d'échanger avec plus de
facilité à travers divers programmes
nous pourrons encore mieux nous
connaître et faire perdurer ce qui
caractérise notre île le mélange des
cultures dès que j'ai été élu j'ai mis
une web télé sur le site internet du
conseil général parce qu'au Conseil
général nous faisons beaucoup de choses
et que l'information vers les publics
qui ont droit à des prestations ou
également à des subventions puisse être
la plus large possible et ce site est
aujourd'hui largement fréquenté par les
réunionnés qui peuvent avoir en ligne
directement toutes les réponses aux
questions qui peuvent se poser donc
c'était un site d'information et
aujourd'hui nous allons plus loin nous
créons véritablement une télé 974 mais
pas seulement ouvert au conseil général
et sur nos dispositif mais à toutes les
associations à tous ceux qui veulent
travailler aux sociétés de production
pour faire passer leurs messages
communiquer s'ouvrir et ouvrir à
l'information une communication à
l'ensemble des réunionnis ça sera en
ligne sur Zeop également et j'espère que
cette télé 974 sera la mieux partagée
pour le si n'hésitez pas si vous avez un
reportage un petit flilm même lié à la
vie familiale et ben faites le passer
sur ce site- là pour le partager avec le
plus grand
nombre avec avec cette chaîne de
télévision le département continue de
prouver qu'il est dans l'aair du temps
974 TV n'a qu'une ambition c'est rendre
service et apporter des solutions à tous
les réunionnés quel que soit le milieu
social ou culturel sans aucun intérêt
financier elle consacre l'intégralité de
ces programmes à la Réunion et ses
habitants le Conseil Général de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général au côté des
Réunionnais